the people that run these companies are
what i call culture vultures they feed
off the misery of my people and
these culture vultures make millions off
the deaths of black bodies and
they do this while saying all the time
black lives matter well if they support
black lives matter
then why in the world are they
glorifying black death
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bringing to you the issues and
awareness that you need to know about
the violence on the south side of
chicago but also to build a community
center on this much needed block called
o-block it's called o-block because it's
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the gangs took
the o in his name and started calling it
o block well we like the o but we're
going to change it to opportunity block
i want to thank fox for the opportunity
that they've given me every single day
to bring to america rooftop revelations
to share with you my thoughts viewpoints
and opinions on matters as it relates to
chicago violence and issues that impact
our great country
drill music has been making the news
lately
the new york city mayor recently blamed
drill music for the rise in violence
including the killing of two young
rappers in new york
though the issue is making the news now
there's nothing new about this for us
here on the south side of chicago
nothing new at all
right before me is the very home of
drill
right in front of me are the projects
where it all started
i know of all the rappers i've worked
with them all
i'm not going to name them
in this video because i don't think
they're
the main problem for what we're
experiencing here
here's why
the kids were born into objective
poverty
the worst kind of poverty in america a
poverty
prison so to speak where they're
surrounded by violence and gang-banging
and drugs
it's all they see
they can't see the outside their culture
as they grow up they can't even see it
because of gangs
many of these kids never go more than
four blocks north south west or east
out of their own neighborhood
and drill music
is all they know sometimes
right before me in the early 2010s drill
artists developed this new style of
delivering the lyrics in a dead pan
monotone vocal style
while this delivery style is very
understated the lyrics are not
they're violent really violent drill
means drill the rappers
mean violent they threat each other with
rival gangs and rival rappers and the
result is death
drill music is a major problem but of
what keeps the violence going on the
south side of chicago
and what makes drill music even worse is
that
many of my kids at project hood grew up
believing that drill music is the real
the most authentic world
drill music undermines the very work
that we try to do at project hood
matter of fact all the work that we do
is about being positive
but i don't
put most of the blame on these rappers
what made real music so powerful and
what gave drill music its staying power
in america
are the music corporations
the people that run these companies are
what i call culture vultures they feed
off the misery of my people and
these culture vultures make millions off
the deaths of black bodies and
they do this while saying all the time
black lives matter well if they support
black lives matter
then why in the world are they
glorifying black death
the senselessness of shootings and
killings black bodies
become some of the music's lyrics
sometimes i can't even wrap my head
around all of the senselessness
sometimes i just have to take a step
back and look at the whole
picture ever since i set up our ministry
in this neighborhood over 20 years ago
i've been fighting post-60 liberalism
these liberal folks thought that they
knew how to fix our neighborhood
they know what's best
they bragged about how they were helping
us when
in reality they were curating black
dependency
they bragged about how they
were investing in our neighborhood when
we clearly don't see any fruits of the
so-called investment around here at all
in other words these liberals exploited
black pain for their own
personal
and professional
prestige
they never paid the price for the damage
they did
to our communities
we would have been way better off had
they never tried to help us in the first
place
that's a fact
now i'm seeing the very same thing here
with drill music and
the corporations and radio stations that
profit off this music
these corporate folks they're all doing
the same thing that these liberals do
they they come in
they take this music
they put it on the air
they glorify it
that's a part of our culture our are you
kidding me killing rappers you think
that's a part of our culture
these people make millions
off these lyrics and i know it's
millions because they pay these dirt
poor rappers millions for their lyrics
what dirt poor kid
in the hood is going to say no
what other options do these kids have
that gets them
wealth
insane wealth overnight
i don't hold these kids
totally responsible for their lyrics i
hold them responsible for the lyrics but
not totally responsible because
if it were not for these corporations
keeping the music alive and profiting
off of the dead bodies
then what we're seeing what we're
experiencing
we would not even be seeing it at all
i want to talk about this because
this really
fires me up this drill music is exactly
what i've been fighting against for 22
years i've been trying to teach kids
here in america the values in our hood
what values and principles are about
i've been saying to them how important
it is to take advantage of opportunities
and make the best of their lives
in the midst of poverty trying to let
them know that they can do it
and then here we are in the grasp of
this post-60 liberalism
and these bad policies
and we have to go against this drill
music that teaches the opposite values
and
i have to give eulogies for drill music
victims
it makes the work that we're doing
very difficult
so we need to expose these corporations
these radio djs
for what they truly are culture vultures
they feed off the black pain
that's what they're doing
they're they're they're feeding off
black pain culture vultures as for me
the work continues every single day my
team and i will never stop our work we
know we are doing the right thing we
know these corporations and radio
stations have all the money in the world
and will dismiss our complaints
let them
but we will never stop doing our work
the culture vultures promise death we
promote life
we promote doing it a better way
but not these culture vultures
they're only interested in the money
they don't care about black lives
they don't care about young black men
killing one another
use the word ops
and the n-word
as much as you want degrade women as
much as you want here take this money
we'll pay you over and over and over
again
why
because that's what culture vultures do
that's all i want to say about this
as i always say thank you fox for
another opportunity
to bring you my thoughts viewpoints and
opinions
to share with you
an america rooftop revelations
thank you to eli steele for producing
such a wonderful
show thank you to terrell
for filming
and as i always say
another rooftop revelation
and until tomorrow god bless you god
bless america
peace
you